joining me now is victor davis hansen
hoover institution senior fellow
victor um
pete isn't really hiding his ambition
but
you think about this i mean the guy
couldn't run south bend indiana well
which was a disaster when he was mayor
so is he gonna do to the presidency what
he's done to air travel this summer
yeah i think he would i mean the problem
with the biden agenda is that nobody
likes what he's doing they feel it's
destroying the country and he's doing
everything the hard left wanted so then
they're floating the name of somebody
who would even be more nihilistic on the
border on crime on inflation on gas he's
even worse than biden so then they look
at biden and harris and they say well
their personalities don't uplift the
agenda because they're incoherent for
various reasons but then when you look
at him
uh he polls even worse with minorities
that are trying to attract and his
record as the
transportation secretary has been a
disaster laura the highway system nobody
can afford to drive the airline industry
is in shambles the poor if you go out to
the port of la there's ships stacked up
to the horizon there's wild west train
robbering on the tracks of trains
entering the port and he doesn't care he
talks about the racist origins of the
freeway system or he's going to
diversify the cockpit but anything that
he talks about has no relevance to
voters just like biden's talk voters
don't want to hear climate change they
don't want to hear transgenderism they
don't even want to hear about abortion
they have four or five issues that
they're concerned about
and
but a jig would just multiply the
problems they had that he's a product of
the bicoastal professional class that
appreciates his glibness his
sanctimoniousness his self-righteousness
they like his repartee but that won't
appeal to anybody outside their small
cadre no but victor he went to the
essence festival
that is he went to the essence festival
it's an amazing time but that's
what he that that's what constitutes
outreach for him
i i mean that is just bad yeah he talks
idiotic he talks down and go if you like
the music americans the way that jill
biden does to latinos it's it's
condescending it's fake it's not genuine
and people understand that that's why
they voted overwhelmingly in the primary
to reject him it wasn't because he was
gay it was because he was self-righteous
and full of himself and he was glib and
he
he set the as i said he set the academic
lounge on fire they loved it but and
translated in the real world he's just
going to take that losing agenda further
to the left and he brings no personal
counterweight in the way that biden
doesn't either or harris i think he's
more unpopular than camilla harris or
biden
well i think also victor
democrats keep thinking they have a
messaging problem that if they just had
a different messenger
the policies would go over better right
but that's not the case they have a
policy problem not not necessarily a
messaging problem that's a good point
that's a good point laura if biden
hadn't inherited every one of trump's
policies and left it on change and
plagiarized it like is his want and said
that it was his we would be talking what
a vigorous 79 year old he is right now
they'd say mine this is spectacular look
at the low inflation affordable gas the
crime is rate is still low this is great
um and the border is secure where the
wall will be proceeding and biden is 79
and he did all this so it's not his it's
not even his age it's that's a force
multiplying effect but you're right it's
the agenda and he's he's managed in a
year and a half to basically destroy the
country to the extent that a president
can in such a short time
well the left is now understanding that
the working class has abandoned the
democrat party or the democrats have
abandoned the working class victor in 20
seconds can the democrats in a short
period of time win them back
no we talked about that with the
virginia elections remember laura we
said you asked if you said they weren't
gonna they weren't gonna change they
were gonna double down and they did and
they will continue to do that victor
great to see you as always tonight